mr gutfeld we have not heard from you
for a long time what is your reaction to
what you've seen over the last five days
well i mean it's it's soul-crushing i
mean i have uh trying to get my
mother-in-law out of kiev
and uh and um you know i have friends
that are russian i have a lot of friends
who are ukrainian it's obvious this is
an unprovoked war but it's also a family
squabble
you know the big picture has always been
you know
who is ukraine more important to is it
russia or is it us
obviously it's russia it's that border
it's those people it's long-standing
family it's long-standing loves as well
as disputes that have been going on it's
not us however we are involved because
we're allies to ukraine and we also work
with russia that's what that's the way
the world is now so we can't help but
get involved even if
even if it's like a fight that's
happening in another side of town
between two families and it's none of
our damn business but it is our business
it's hard to watch you want to root
against the bully putin
but i'm afraid if we emboldened the
bully's target the bully increases his
brutality
you can root for zilinski and the heroic
ukrainians and we should i hope they win
but this isn't a sports team this isn't
fiction we have no skin in this game
unfortunately i have skin in this game
so it makes me look at this differently
but picking sides and cheering right now
it's too soon and i hope russia loses
uh
but i don't know i mean i if i had to
choose between russia losing
and this ending quickly i would just say
end it quickly because this is tragic
these are two countries with extreme
similar
similarities in their lives and their
histories and their religions
putin always wanted ukraine we know that
but that's not even debatable if that's
the end game then what's our end game
right i mean do we fight for the
ukrainian freedom or do we go back to
the original question which is who is
ukrainian more important to
you know russia or us i'm sorry to hear
that you have family there and we all
wish
it is my mother-in-law so technically
that's a joke
uh we right now let's go back to trey
yanks who's in kiev with the latest trey
can you hear us
guys i've got you now tonight ukrainian
president beloved zielinski is calling
once again on the international
community to close the airspace over
ukraine we've seen more missile attacks
against this city tonight air raid
sirens sounding out sending people once
again into bomb shelters and it comes
amid some concerning new satellite
images from maxar technologies
indicating there is a 17-mile long
convoy of russian troops logistics
troops and ground forces headed toward
the capital of kiev and they're just 15
miles outside the city as we speak this
is significant as the air and ground
campaign against the capital and other
major cities like kharkiv the second
largest ukrainian city continues now we
do know also the civilians here are
preparing for the worst they have seen
over the weekend a direct impact from
this war a missile slamming into an
apartment building killing at least two
people and many women and children are
waiting out in hospitals and other
facilities they hope won't be targeted
some heartbreaking images of mothers
waiting with their children in these
facilities and the words of one really
standing out amid the mix listen to what
she had to say
we'll receive all medicine we need that
we are running out of food local charity
fans promise to bring some we are
waiting that they will come and bring us
bread essential and some juice for
children
the words from these ukrainian civilians
come amid the backdrop of peace talks
that took place today along the border
between ukraine and belarus between the
ukrainians and the russians a stark
contrast in what the two sides looked
like the ukrainians showed up wearing
military fatigues the russians suits and
ties we also know that ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky once again
is calling for the airspace to be closed
over this country he wants this air
campaign to stop so his forces have a
better shot at winning this war back to
you thanks trey so judge similar to last
week we saw coming the move towards the
capitol it's not going as fast i think
as the russians thought it would be but
as you can see from the reporting
they're going in and they're amassing
around the city
at this point it's just a matter of how
long can the people there hold out and
can zielinski survive that encirclement
well the amazing part of it is that
zielinski and the ukrainian people have
been incredibly strong they have taken
russia and the world by surprise and i
think it speaks to the issue of the
comments that you know uh zielinski is a
you know just a comedian who ran for
office patriotism is not something that
is defined by being a politician as a
patriot you can be you can be determined
and you can love your country and you
can lead your people to fight and that's
exactly what we're seeing the ukrainians
are freedom loving people and greg to a
certain extent i agree with what you say
and that you know it's kind of can be
conceived as a family fight one of my
best friends is from russia but her
mother was born in ukraine
and so they are part of the same the
kinship there but you see this isn't
anything that we can look at and say oh
let them do their thing this is about
raw power going after the the map of
europe and now we're seeing for the
first time since world war ii
russian tanks on the on the plains of
europe and they will not stop here they
will continue to go so the question is
you know is putin holding back is he
just doing the 1100 military
installations not affecting the
infrastructure because he wants to
occupy and therefore use the
infrastructure and you know is he
intentionally going a little slower but
is he now saying these people are
stronger than i thought now i'm going to
hit civilians we'll see yeah i mean of
course they could just have screwed up
supply lines and a bad initial strategy
because the russians usually are sloppy
and slow but brutal katie and we just i
think gave the ukrainians a bunch of
stingers for the very first time and our
javelins are having a huge effect well
greg brought up the question of
who was ukraine more important to the
united states or russia and right now
the president of ukraine believes
ukraine is important to the ukrainian
people and they want to be their own
sovereign country and he addressed this
issue of russians living in ukraine
being born in ukraine ukrainians being
there the night before the invasion in
that speech when he spoke in russian
directly to the russian people and said
we are two different countries but we
share many different uh cultures and we
can live
with next to each other in peace and we
don't want this war and you're seeing in
russia now a number of thousands of
people protesting the streets against
what putin has done now there's been
this question about what putin's fame
and mind is we don't know people are
calling him crazy we don't know what
he's thinking but we do have a history
of the way he has behaved in other parts
in the world and what he's been able to
get away with in places like syria and
so as you see reports of him using uh
cluster bombs for example that does not
bode well for what's to come however you
are seeing this resupply of um of the
ukrainian military from places like
germany who haven't been giving arms to
anybody for for decades for obvious
reasons um so the ukrainian people are
clearly the ones who are not fighting
not making molotov cocktails not picking
up the guns the ones in the basements
are in a raw pure human form of survival
and time's running out when it comes to
getting supplies with water and food and
watching these orphanages
is just heartbreaking um but i think
that in terms of the question of who who
it matters to right now is the people
who are fighting in the streets and
they're going to hold out as long as
they can
as long as they have the military
ability to do so and the 17-mile long
convoy that you're seeing seems like a
pretty good target for the jets that
they're about to get from the eu so
we'll see how it goes but
their fighting spirit is certainly
admirable that convoy just blasted to
smithereens do you think that putin
underestimated the ferocity of the
civilian population and and and their
patriotism to stand up and fight i think
he has
uh my prayers go out and the best to
your to your mother-in-law and your
family uh greg there on the ground uh
but i differ a little bit in terms i
think this is important to people who
believe in independence and freedom um
this is a sovereign line putin cross
there's a lot of pain there's a lot we
have to deal with and wrestle with here
but you think about where we are i think
we're closer to the ending that many of
us want it may still be a little painful
to get there but i think we're closer to
where we are where we want those of us
who uh would like to see him removed
from there perhaps even removed from
power in russia think about this the
miscalculation he's made putin has made
may cost him power in his own nation may
cost him the opportunity to lead his own
nation number one number two greg part
of what you were saying think about this
we've invested trillions since world war
ii in the architecture there i don't
need to tell you this i'm just not a
history lesson but we've invested
trillions there then after 94 but we've
invested and these these people not only
in ukraine but all across europe think
about the marshall plan to where we are
today this was all about building an
architecture that based on independence
and freedom and democracy
without question the most surprising
thing has been the ukrainians desire to
own their own land to own their own
freedom uh and to own their own futures
uh and i can only hope that what we're
doing what germany's doing what nato is
doing and what others are doing in terms
of providing them with resources and
even now weaponry weekend debate should
have happened sooner these are all
hypotheticals it's happening now and my
prayers are with them and i hope they
they use these things we send them in a
way to not only repel vladimir putin but
to propel their democracy and their
independence even more here hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else